we all know that the products we manage
at some point must turn a profit so
whether you're working at a large
corporation with many products to manage
or churning away at a young startup
still searching for product market fit
everyone working in products
needs to have a basic knowledge of the
financial and cost accounting measures
that lead to profit
i'm mike levink professor of civil and
environmental engineering at stanford
and in this class i will show you how to
use the concepts of accounting and cost
management to make decisions and drive
product profitability
how to leverage the tools of accounting
and cost management to set product
targets and measure performance
and how to build upon the ideas of
accounting and cost management to plan
for product success and deliver value
don't worry i won't ask you to be a cpa
or to do any overly advanced math
but what i will show you is how to use
things like balance sheets income
statements and other financial documents
to make better product focused decisions
how to think more critically about
product pricing and cost and then manage
for product profit
and how to create product focus targets
and goals that align with your customers
your team and your company
i look forward to seeing you there